hagamos una relación entre las variables
xy entonces digamos que esta columna
corresponde a la variable x y está la
variable y cuando x es igual a 1 y es
igual a 4 cuando x es igual a 2 y es
igual a 8 cuando x es igual a 3 que será
igual a 12 y tal vez si inmediatamente
te das cuenta que esta es una relación
proporcional recuerda que para que la
relación sea proporcional la razón entre
las dos variables es siempre constante
entonces por ejemplo si tenemos ya entre
x voy a escribirlo si tenemos que entre
x
esto es igual veamos aquí en el primer
renglón tenemos y entre x es igual a 4
sobre 1 eso es igual a 4 en el segundo 8
sobre 12 es igual a 4 en el tercero 12
sobre 3 es igual a 4
entonces ya sobre x es igual a 4 siempre
es igual a 4 de hecho puedo agregar aquí
otra columna donde tengo la razón
x entonces esta columna corresponde a la
razón y / x y / x para el primer renglón
tenemos 4 sobre 1 eso es igual a 4 en el
segundo renglón 8 sobre 2 es igual a 4 y
en el tercer renglón 12 sobre 3 es igual
a 4 así que puedes usar esta información
la razón entre jay x es igual a la
constante 4 para expresar la relación
entre x como una ecuación de hecho esto
ya es una ecuación pero puedo hacerlo un
poco más claro puedo multiplicar ambos
lados de esta ecuación por la variable x
entonces hago eso voy a multiplicar el
lado izquierdo por la variable xy el
lado derecho también la multiplicó por
la variable x así que aquí tenemos x / x
eso es igual a 1 entonces me queda y es
igual a 4x y puedes ver que ese es el
caso aquí cuando x es igual a 14 por 1
es igual a 4 cuando x es igual a 2
tenemos que 4 por 2 es igual a 8
entonces estamos multiplicando por
cuatro lo escribo estamos multiplicando
por cuatro por cuatro
también aquí estamos multiplicando por
cuatro
estamos multiplicando
4 entonces eso quiere decir que el 4 en
este caso es nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad lo escribo el 4 en este
caso es nuestra constante
proporcionalidad proporcionalidad
nuestra constante de proporcionalidad
ahora en ocasiones tal vez se le pueda
describir como una razón de cambio y tal
vez te preguntes bueno y esto como puede
ser una razón de cambio para que quede
un poco más claro a de otro ejemplo pero
en este nuevo ejemplo voy a poner
unidades entonces bueno hagamos este
nuevo ejemplo donde pongo unidades así
que digamos que tengo a x tenemos a la
variable x que es una medida de tiempo y
tenemos a la variable y que es una
medida de distancia entonces esta ley
está en términos de metros y la equis
estará en términos de segundos
entonces bueno digamos que después de un
segundo hemos viajado siete metros
después de dos segundos hemos viajado 14
metros y después de tres segundos hemos
viajado 21 metros y puedes verificar que
esta es una relación proporcional la
razón entre jay x es siempre 7 pero
quiero escribirlo en términos de sus
unidades entonces para el primer renglón
tenemos 7 metros sobre un segundo 7
sobre 1 eso es igual a 7 y nos queda
metros sobre segundos para el segundo
renglón tenemos tenemos ya sobre x es
igual a 14 metros tenemos 14 metros
sobre 2 segundos 14 sobre 2 eso es igual
a 7 metros sobre segundos y es por eso
que a esta constante a este 7 como tú
puedes ver en todos los casos tenemos
que ye sobre x es igual a 7 entonces lo
escribo y es sobre x es igual a 7 lo
puedes ver en todos los casos
a este 7 a esta constante en ocasiones
se le considera la razón la razón aquí
lo puedes ver más claro aquí tenemos la
distancia sobre el tiempo 7 metros sobre
un segundo ahí tenemos ahí tenemos claro
que es la razón es constante 7 ahora si
yo quisiera escribir lo de una forma más
general podríamos pensar en que si
estamos trabajando con una relación de
proporción esta sería la forma siempre
puedes construir una una ecuación de
esta forma que sobre x es igual acá
donde acá es una constante ahora puedes
ver que en este primer ejemplo tenemos
que la constante k es igual a 4 y en el
segundo ejemplo la constante k es igual
a 7 ahora en esta ecuación ya sobre x
igual a k podrías manipular la
algebraica mente
podrías multiplicar ambos lados por xy
lo que obtienes es que es igual a k por
x donde k es una constante de
proporcionalidad
esta ecuación ye igual acá por equis en
muchas ocasiones es una idea muy
sencilla y es bueno que puedas reconocer
esta ecuación como una ecuación de
proporcionalidad